au hit parade des fromages français le
reblochon vient de décrocher la
quatrième place des ventes un producteur
artisanal d'art busigny en haute savoie
nous explique les raisons de ce succès
on a connu une petite crise quand même
ces dernières années mais apparemment le
reblochon repart de plus belle et on en
est d'autant plus satisfait la
haute-savoie peut se réjouir le
reblochon repart en effet de plus belle
et se place en quatrième position
nationale il s'en est vendu l'an passé
plus de quinze mille tonnes un succès
spectaculaire auprès des consommateurs
qui apprécient de plus en plus ce
fromage crème est typiquement montagnard
il s'agit d'un produit issu du terroir
savoyards et que de la reflète tout une
image qui apparemment séduit le
consommateur
l'engouement des consommateurs pour les
produits du terroir et le retour aux
traditions serait donc les principales
explications à l'étonnante expansion du
reblochon un créneau qui arrange bien la
fruitière d'art busigny dernière
coopérative fromagère du département
être encore la propriété des
agriculteurs ici le fromage roi des
savoie se fabrique deux fois par jour le
lait arrive directement près la traite
pour être immédiatement transformée
c'est l'image de marque que l'on
souhaite développer parce que le fait de
travailler à l'ancienne en conservant
toute la qualité de la matière première
donne satisfaction client et en est
reconnaissant par le volume de vente qui
accueille augmenter cette année les
consommateurs ne s'y trompe pas en effet
la fruitière d'arbres zini a augmenté
ses ventes de 10% l'an passé et
l'ouverture du magasin de fromages du
terroir est un succès